Give me your hands.
I don't even do this anymore.
Your brother, I'm telling you he's just funny. He's really for real.
He could make money doing this.
For a while, he had an office, a website, newspaper articles, even a book written about him.
So, what happened?
He couldn't cope.
Can I ask you any question?
The job I had before was as a psychic.
What do you think happens when we die?
I recognize you, you're that psychic.
I have news for you, I don't do it anymore.
I give you my word, I won't tell anyone.
You have a duty to do it 'cause you have a gift.
It's not a gift, Billy. It's a curse.
But I think you experienced death.
Listen, listen. Everything I have, I've lost!
If you are worried about being on your own, don't be.
You're not.
Hereafter.